[Music]
what's going on guys welcome back to the
channel
today we have a 2019 nissan altima we're
going to be programming a intelligent
key to it
let's get to it
first thing we want to do in this
process is turn on the caution lights
[Music]
we want to go to nat's nissan anti-theft
system
when performing key registration
any ksu program must all be present at
once any keys that are not available
will be locked out
we are going to access our 20-digit
anti-theft password
through the internet
now that we've pulled our pen we can go
into programming mode
i'm gonna hold the butt until the
ignition comes on
now that we have the ignition on
we're gonna turn it back off
we're gonna press the button
you can see it's flashing
we're gonna hold our key up to it
the ignition will come back on the
lights will flash five times
i'm gonna turn our ignition back off
we're gonna press the button
it's gonna flash again we're gonna hold
our key back up
and the ignition will come back on
and clear out
we'll turn the ignition back off
key registration is complete
[Music]
now with our new key
she fires right up